all right CBS News has an exclusive look
inside the growing immigration crisis
CBS Evening News anchor and managing
editor Noor O'Donnell visited the u.s.
Mexico border she got rare access to the
largest migrant processing facility in
the u.s. in McAllen Texas
Nora Expo sclusively with the Acting
Secretary of Homeland Security and met
some of the thousands of migrant
families who were caught up in the
crisis where are you from - Venezuela
Venezuela and you travel the whole way
with your son
I'm walking Angelina Estrada and her
two-year-old son Martin is just one of
the 815 families here a journalist who
says she was threatened by the
Venezuelan government and knows the law
that as a mother with a child she will
be allowed to enter the United States
are you getting warm food but you're
sleeping on the floor si
it's extraordinary to see mothers and
their children sleeping together on the
floor in the 77,000 square foot facility
the toughest thing to see these infants
alone
napping mid-morning in this makeshift
nursery they are just some of the nearly
300 unaccompanied children here we had
exclusive access to this facility there
was no one we weren't allowed to speak
with and nowhere we couldn't go was any
of this cleaned up or dressed up for us
no we were here with kevin mchale Enon
acting secretary of homeland security I
made the decision to take the risk and
bringing cameras in to be transparent
about what we're facing and make sure
that our Congress knows what we need to
help us address this crisis a year ago
the country was shocked by still photos
showing children being held in
overcrowded cages today it is cleaner
and more well organized but it is still
hard to look at you're the acting
secretary right you're saying this is
not good enough I've been saying it for
a year McClellan's says the solution is
this so-called tent city named Donna
which is expanding he says it is far
better suited to house new migrants the
big challenge we overcrowding as people
are uncomfortable because there's too
many in small areas we're gonna be able
to reduce that really hard to watch no
other mother having to be interviewed
through a fence you know and the emotion
is right there on the surface two or
three questions and tears I keep
thinking about these people that are so
desperate to get away from the
conditions where they're living but they
want to come to a place where they know
they're not even welcome when they get
here it's still better than where what
they've come in much rather come here
and take their chances heartbreaking it
is you can see more of Nora's exclusive
reporting tonight on the CBS Evening
News she'll take us to the banks of the
Rio Grande River where the journey into
the u.s. immigration system began for
the families that she met